welcome thank you for joining us today
for our webinar to present you our
in-situ Plex platform that combines high
level multiplexing with spatial
information on single tissue slides
so why does the combination of
multiplexing and spatial information
matter in the context of immune oncology
pathologists are realizing the growing
complexity they can tap into when
analyzing the tumor microenvironment
it's biology contains a wide variety of
heterogeneous population of cells such
as immune cells and tumor cells the
ability to capture how they interplay
interconnect within the tumor section
may better inform prognosis and patient
stratification this growing need for a
high number of markers is especially
increased by the development of
combination therapies as an example of
the value that can be derived by
combining multiplexing with spatial
information here's an excerpt from a
publication recently made by dr. bernie
Fox and dr. Z beifong first I looked at
the presence of pl1 and noticed that in
and of itself I didn't hold any
prognostic mark power on the other hand
when they looked at the proximity of PDL
1 positive tumor cells next to cd8
t-cells they were able to stratify
patients those patients that showed a
lower number of these PDL one tumor
cells next to cytotoxic t-cells showed a
better prognosis
Alti view is uniquely positioned on the
biomarker discovery value chain we sit
on the sweet spot of this combination of
high level multiplexing from the single
to double digit number of markers and
spatial resolution
our unique selling point resides in the
offering of reagent platform that will
be compatible with the wide range of
instrumentation that is currently there
on the market ranging from auto Stanners
to imaging scanners our reagents are
meant to be used both in an upstream
exploratory use case where the need for
multiplexing is high and the number of
samples to be run on a given assay is
lower and downstream in the routine use
cases running clinical trials with a
signature of biomarkers already narrowed
down so by design lower level of
multiplexing and a higher level of
samples to run with our business model
at its core relies on the
commercialization of these high quality
reagents there are three ways we
interact with our customers for the
upcoming year in 2018 we will launch a
portfolio of kits that will fully be
compatible with the wide range of
instrumentation out of Staters and
multispectral imaging scanners these
kids will be designed in such a way that
they will seamlessly integrate with
these existing workflows as of today
we're engaging with customers through
FIFA services where we receive samples
that will run on behalf of our customer
either on standard panels that have
already been validated internally or
custom panels based on specific requests
made by our customers in some selected
few cases we also extend the service in
a further partnership where we can
explore further ways to deeply connect
with our customer base
in a nutshell our value proposition
touches on HIGH multiplexing institute
the ability to record an unlimited
number of markers on single tissue
slides while keeping the spatial
information intact and we do so while
fully preserving the antigenicity and
integrity of the samples our reagent
platform will be widely applicable to
the full range of instrumentation other
Stanners imaging scanners and is as of
today applicable to any FFP tissue slide
our technology is also amenable to very
high throughput by virtue of the fact
that we rely as you will see on a single
staining step and single amplification
step regardless of the number of markers
you would be looking at on these single
tissue slides and of course the kids
that we will launch in 2018 will be
meant to be fully plug-and-play easy to
use seamlessly integrated in existing
workflows and instruments
without further ado let's dive into the
data that we are able to generate with
our in-situ Plex reagents the images
that you're looking at were captured
from a tonsil tissue slide looking at a
five Plex panel composed of Dappy c d3
t 67p d1 and cytokeratin the image on
the left hand side is a 20x
magnification zoomed out portion of that
tonsil tissue the image on the right
hand side is a zoomed in section of one
of the lymph node of the tonsil
going into the nuts and bolts of our
Institute Lex platform our technology
relies on DNA mediated fluorescence we
introduce an intermediate bridge
composed of two complimentary DNA
strands between the antibody and the
label one strand the barcode is
covalently attached to the FC domain of
the antibody it's complementary form the
label to a floor for our technology's
robustness is guaranteed by three
building blocks the inner conjugation
that ties into the specificity of the
platform where we guarantee that the act
of conjugation of our bar codes to the
antibody does not impair the underlying
performance of that antibody and also in
the way we design pairs of barcodes and
label we make sure that there's no cross
reactivity between any given two pairs
DNA amplification ties to the
sensitivity of our platform whereby we
can elongate and extend the length of
any given barcode to create a polymer on
top of these barcodes a bit like
branches of a Christmas tree on which
you'll be able to attach many more
labels themselves conjugated to to floor
force as a result you increase the ratio
of barcodes per antibody and therefore
the amount of floor force that can
hybridize through the label onto the
antibody what guarantees the
reversibility of our platform is what we
call DNA exchange the act of D
hybridizing at will the labels from
their barcodes
at any point in time
so how did we generate the five kliks
images that you saw before
after conjugating five different
barcodes to the antibody specific to the
markers of interest we applied them in a
single staining step subsequently we
apply a single amplification step to
increase the relative ratio of barcodes
per antibody at this point in time
there's still no four essence on the
sample we come in with our first wave of
labels that will hybridize to the first
marker in this case CD 3 we switched on
CD 3 we require an image we come in with
our proprietary buffer that will reverse
the hybridization d hybridize the labels
from its barcodes and we can wash away
the fluorescence from the sample we are
back to zero for essence and we can
iterate as many times as you want the
second step was switching on cd8 by
introducing the label specific to the
corresponding barcode using the same
channel we're using the same floor for
in this workflow after acquiring five
different images of the five different
markers we can overlay them using adapt
counter stain as you can see this method
of sequential multiplexing is fully
reversible it relies on a single
staining single amplification step and
it starts without fir essence and ends
without fluorescence to illustrate our
DNA mediated amplification method we've
compared the results that we are able to
generate with our method on PD one in
tonsil tissue versus a traditional dye
label secondary based amplification
method as you can see with our
amplification method we are able to
generate a much higher signal-to-noise
ratio these images left and right were
acquired on the same instrument same
exposure time
our approach to remove the fluorescence
from the sample by D hybridizing the
labels from their underlying barcodes
relies on a method that fully preserved
the integrity and antigenicity of the
sample we avoid the use of microwave
heat light peroxide of any other
detergent and we don't change the pH nor
the salt concentration of the buffer in
presence of the sample we use an enzyme
whose function is solely to D hybridize
the label without damaging the antigens
and while preserving as well the
barcodes and the antibodies that always
stay on the sample to demonstrate this
full preservation we've done multiple
cycles looking at the same two markers
in this case cytokeratin and ki67 over
six consecutive cycles of hybridization
and D hybridization as you can see the
image that we obtained before and after
these cycles were exactly comparable the
same experiment to demonstrate the full
reversibility of our reagents was
performed by our collaborator david rim
and Yale pathology labs he used the same
markers cytokeratin and ki-67 over a
number of consecutive imaging rounds and
demonstrated likewise the full removal
of fluorescence and the full
comparability of the subsequent images
he was able to image after hybridizing
the labels on the same barcodes our
collaborator david rim also assessed the
inter sample reproducibility of our in
situ plex platform by comparing two
serial sections together looking at cd3
cytokeratin ki-67 he analyzed the result
using a highly quantitative software
platform the aqua platform and observed
exactly comparable results
across the two sections thanks to the
reversibility of our Institute Plex
reagent platform we can compare
head-to-head images acquired in
immunofluorescence with images acquired
with traditional IHC in this example we
first acquired cd3 in NS CLC using our
immunofluorescent based approach with
labels attached to floor force then
after removing the fluorescence from the
sample we came in with an h RP label
secondary antibody that we applied on
the same tissue section and generated
the corresponding chromogenic image that
we could intern compared to the first
immunofluorescent image we had generated
how can you access our technology today
we currently engage with customers
through selected pilot studies where we
act as a CRO customers will select the
markers of interest we will design and
develop the corresponding assay collect
samples from our customers run them on
on their behalf and return the raw
images to them that the customer in
turns interprets a typical project flow
lasts between three or four month
depending on the level of multiplexing
and the complexity of the underlying
markers to conclude I will leave you
with a typical example of a pilot study
in this case the seven planks acquired
in NS CLC FFPE samples looking at CD 3
cd4 cd8 granzin B TT f1p d1 and that be
the corresponding raw images were
formatted to be analyzed on the halo
platform for further cell segmentation I
hope you've enjoyed this webinar feel
free to visit our website and to reach
out to us for any questions thank you